erst recht aber richtig geil alter
[Musik]
alter ticker
[Applaus]
irgendwie einfach leipziger koch man
[Musik]
etwas glaubt und jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video ich weiß nicht vielleicht
sieht zwanziger wir haben gemerkt woran
ich bin gerade erst aufgestanden und
meine stimme ist und nicht so warm dass
merk ich gerade selber als ich heute
ursprünglich heute um 9 uhr aufstehen um
dann dieses video schön entspannt zeit
zu haben ich musste er noch einkaufen
dafür
naja dann war es plötzlich doch 11 uhr
kennt ihr das euer wecker klingelt und
dann ist er irgendwie weg wieder warum
auch immer und dann klingt er nicht
nochmals ein bisschen blöd aber dennoch
drehe ich jetzt dieses video für euch
ich weiß nicht wie ich draufgekommen bin
ich bin einfach irgendwie drauf gekommen
wahrscheinlich einfach nur weil ich gern
süßigkeiten es auf jeden fall jagt sie
wahrscheinlich am liebsten gelesen es
geht heute darum wie ich süßigkeiten
brato ganz doof gesagt ich hab mich
einfach mal gefragt was passiert wenn
man zum beispiel die schlümpfe oder hier
so haribo oder eventuell toffifee oder
ganz vielleicht auch smarties was
passiert mit smarties
wenn man die bre also jetzt nicht
einfach nur in die falle tun und nichts
machen sondern halt so mit sahne
mehr kann ich nicht ja darum dreht sich
das heutige video ich hoffe ja bock
drauf und wir gucken einfach mal was
passiert ich würde sagen wenn das video
geil wird und ihr bock auf dem zweiten
teil machen wir das bald 13.500 likes
ich will gar nicht lang lagern wir
fangen an biss sofort wie ihr seht ich
bin ja
christel von irgendwelchen sachen auf
jeden fall habe ich das jetzt so geplant
hier ist ja die kamera gefilmt die ganze
zeit auch die fahne und mit dieser
kamera spreche ich ab und zu aber ich
will gar nicht zu häufig sprechen weil
wir wollen ja alle sehen was passiert
und ja ich will gar nicht eingeladen
habe ich ja gerade schon mal gesagt es
ist echt zum spruch den habe ich
bestimmt insgesamt schon 200 mal gesagt
also würde ich gar nicht glauben und 1
war ja ich stelle mal kurz diese kamera
auf jeden fall ist es ja logisch man
muss erstmal ein bisschen öl in die
pfanne
giessen ok dies auf jeden fall schon war
so jetzt kommt erstmal ein bisschen öl
ein ich weiß gar nicht ich kenne mich
damit jetzt auch nicht so gut aus ich
würde sagen wir fangen wir mit den
schlimmsten an oder ist das schon war es
passiert ja das ist normal dass jetzt
nichts passiert das ist vollkommen
normal er langsam gehts los
zumal nach dem verein
[Musik]
wichtig was man da durchaus noch mal
machen kann sandra scheiße passiert ihr
seid ein 1 1 1 1
klasse gemacht so ich will mal sagen ich
weiß jetzt nicht was wir den schlümpfen
noch passiert das war jetzt natürlich
und nicht so krass aber ich glaube da
passiert auf jeden fall mit mehr aber
nicht schlimm für die haben so die sind
flüssig geworden wir weiter zur nächsten
runde wird sagen wir nehmen einfach mal
schnell die toffees ich mir das alles
ganz entspannt zum schluss es muss hier
erstmal alles abkühlen obwohl ich würde
sagen das muss erstmal ein bisschen
erhitzen
[Musik]
was passiert mit dem trickfilm dass
armin veh
das gibt aber gute ich wollte gerade
drauf machen aber ich glaube das lassen
wir besser machen
ach komm scheiß drauf
[Musik]
der kommende jetzt das ja ich weiß jetzt
nicht hier so da passiert jetzt nichts
spezielles
es riecht aber richtig geil alter so
leute jetzt bin ich auf jeden fall mal
richtig gespannt und zwar kommen wir
jetzt zu den mars - alter die zerstören
das habe ich im gefühl so es kommt ein
bisschen neues bratl rein
jetzt bin ich mal richtig gespannt wo
leute alter spiele ich jetzt hier rein
gemacht habt weiter
das wird zum richtiger kuchen mann
kommen weiter machen weiter los
die schmerzen richtig zusammen hält
boa leute guckt euch das mal elf wie
soll das ist ein richtiger vulkan der
seeleute wie katz ist das denn
wie krass sorgen dass abgekühlt ist
ich gehe mal besser schnell damit nach
draußen alter ticker
[Applaus]
irgendwann einfach heftiger kochmann
kupfer und was bitte das was diese
löcher wenn da was raubüberfall spaß
eigentlich habe ich ja noch die smarties
über ne pas martys noch drauf das wird
nämlich mainz marty gucken jetzt hier
und was natürlich nicht fehlen darf die
sahne
ach du scheiße alex du bist komplett
gestört
das hört sich überhaupt nicht gut an
so ich mache den bis jetzt mal aus heute
kommt mit ab draußen
das muss jetzt noch nicht abkühlen das
ist einfach komplett bestelle ich das
hier zum besten notiert macht er jetzt
sein das ist ja normal von kuchen der
muss ja im kalt so ein bisschen abkühlen
damit er auch gut schmeckt so wir gehen
wieder zurück
naspers na ja leute die haben wir jetzt
auch die schlümpfe und die toffees ist
auch geil geworden auf jeden fall
danke natürlich an dich du hast einmal
noch so ein bisschen pfeffer mit rein
gebracht da ist auch mal ein bisschen
was ab gegangen da drin und ich freu
mich erstmal auf wir sehen uns gleich
wieder
dann probieren wir den chipmarkt rein
okay leute willkommen zurück wundert
euch nicht meine haare sind nass ich
habe gerade geduscht das ist alles jetzt
ein bisschen abgekühlt und in der zeit
habe ich halt geduscht diese nicht
fertig oder sonst irgendwas wollte was
sagen ja kleines problem
hier sieht man noch ein paar schlümpfe
und auch die toffees die waren im müll
ich hab's unten stehen lassen und jemand
aus meiner familie dachte sich kommt das
mäuschen müll also probiere ich jetzt
gleich praktisch was aus müll
toni macht aber das andere die recht
heftig aus als ich würde sagen wir
fangen einfach mal schnell mit einem
schlumpf an und hab ich das nämlich in
sämtlichen also schlumpf aus dem müll
das wirkt unglaublich scheiße das war
einmal fünfter schmeckt die popkomm mit
schokolade also tobi ist kann man echt
beraten
flecker toffees gebrachten aus müll so
läuft jetzt schaut euch einfach mal das
meisterwerk das war mal so ein richtiger
kuchen aber irgendwie ist das getrocknet
und jetzt ist das hier zwischen es
einfach schokolade und karamell von den
smarties also ich kratze mahlgrad ein
bisschen zusammen also noch die nummer
eins
interessanter geschmacks mcvicar email
mit zuckerwatte hier ist noch ein ganzes
martin
ich finde das auge isst mit das sieht
schon echte cowboys oder cooper problem
ist jetzt nur wie ich die fahne wieder
sauber kriegen also leute ich würde
sagen ich hab mir vielleicht die ein
oder anderen süßigkeiten rausgesucht die
man nicht so gut beraten kann ihr könnt
ja in die kommentare schreiben was
glaubt ihr
welche fähigkeiten kann man gut beraten
die danach auch lecker schmecken
schreibt einfach mal die kommentare ich
lese das natürlich durch und dann gibt's
dazu wahrscheinlich im zweiten teil bei
13.500 likes wenn man nämlich gesagt
instagram 86 laptop würde mich sehr
freuen folgt auf jeden fall und wir
sehen uns dann übermorgen oder morgen
wieder wer würde noch einen schönen tag
haut rein